in diesem video zeige ich euch einen
super einfachen trick mit dem ihr aus
der gleichen anzahl basilikum pflanzen
dreimal mehr heraus holt oder sogar noch
mehr viele leute kaufen basilikum ja im
supermarkt vielleicht selbst du das auch
selber aus und pflanzt das dann in deine
kübel oder in deinen garten das ist für
dieses video hier ganz egal es ist nun
erstmal ganz wichtig zu verstehen dass
das hier nicht eine pflanze ist auch
wenn das aussieht wie so ein busch aber
wenn man genau hinschaut dann sieht man
dass wir ganz viele kleine
unterschiedliche stengel aus der erde
heraus wachsen und um den trick zu
verstehen den ich euch heute zeige es
ist erstmal wichtig dass man versteht
dass jedes einzelne von denen hier eine
einzelne pflanze ist das heißt in diesem
töpfchen wachsen ich überschlag das
jetzt mal coop ungefähr 30 pflanzen und
nicht nur eine diejenigen von euch die
sich basilikum aus dem supermarkt kaufen
werden wahrscheinlich unterschreiben da
es ist super schwierig ist die am leben
zu halten die sind so empfindlich und
die gehen so schnell ein und deswegen
kommt am ende des videos noch mal ein
trick wir diejenigen von euch die sich
diese töpfchen wir kaufen sodass die
ewig lange leben und nicht eingehen also
bis zum ende dran bleiben das lohnt sich
viele leute zupfen wenn sie ihr
basilikum ernten einfach immer nur so
einzelne blätter ab aber macht das nicht
es gibt eine clevere art wie man
basilikum ernten kann und gleichzeitig
das wachstum extrem anregt und wie das
funktioniert das zeige ich euch jetzt
hier stehen drei pflanzen dicht an dicht
und wenn man genau hinschaut dann sieht
man dass sich bei allen pflanzen die
haupt triebe einfach hier gekappt habe
und was dann passiert ist dass die
pflanze ihre wuchskraft in zwei
seitentriebe steckt die links und rechts
von diesem haupt trieb schon angelegt
waren und so kann man seine erste extrem
potenzieren das heißt hier aus dieser
stelle wachsen jetzt einfach zwei neue
triebe raus hier sieht man das auch ganz
gut hier habe ich gehabt und da wachsen
jetzt aus dieser stelle stadteigenen
betrieb gleich zwei neue seitentriebe
raus und so wird die pflanze immer
buschiger und man kann aus ein und
derselben pflanze viel mehr ernst
rausholen die beiden triebe sind jetzt
schon ein paar zentimeter lang und jetzt
kann das spiel von neuem beginnen wenn
ihr hier schaut dann seht ihr das hier
wieder zwei neue ansätze für neue
seitentriebe gebildet sind und wenn ich
jetzt diese spitze hier ernte und das
einfach hier ab kappe dann kann aus der
stelle hier können 2 neue triebe
entstehen das heißt wir haben einmal
hier geklappt hier entstehen zwei neue
träger jetzt hab ich hier und dann
wachsen hier wieder zwei neue triebe
raus und so kann man seine ernte nicht
nur verdreifachen sondern vervielfachen
mit ein und derselben pflanze
das ist viel sinnvoller als wenn man
immer nur mal hier ein blättchen oder
der blättchen ab knipst also immer
gucken wo sind die triebspitzen und die
wollt ihr dann entfernen und dann
wachsen aus der stelle wieder zwei neue
triebe nach basilikum fängt außerdem
super schnell an zu blühen und wenn die
pflanzen blühen dann schmecken sie so
ein bisschen leicht bitter und sind
nicht mehr so aromatisch
deswegen wollen wir das verhindern außer
natürlich wir wollen unsere samen ernten
das basilikum weiter vermehren weil auch
eine tolle sache ist aber wenn wir das
nur zum essen anders dann ist das super
praktisch wenn wir die pflanzen so
ernten wie ich euch das gerade gezeigt
habe weil die pflanzen dadurch gar keine
möglichkeit haben zu blühen weil die
blühen immer hier oben an den
triebspitzen und wenn wir die immer
kappen beim ernten damit sich das weiter
verzweigt dann können die basilikum
pflanzen gar nicht mehr in die blüte
gehen und wir können quasi endlos ernten
und die kopf basilikum pflanzen aus dem
supermarkt ich schneidet man dann ganz
genauso um das wachstum anzuregen es ist
aber wichtig wenn ihr euch jetzt eine
top hier gekauft habt dass ihr die
pflanzen nicht in diesem kopf stehen was
weil dann das ist kein wunder die
sterben wenn man mal in den kräuterbuch
anschaut dann steht bei basilikum einen
pflanzabstand von 35 x 35 zentimetern
also eigentlich wäre der optimale
abstand zwischen den pflanzen 35
zentimeter und hier sind 35 blumen auch
so ein 12 cm topf zusammen gefährlich
das ist eigentlich basilikum machen
haltung und dann ist es auch kein wunder
dass es unseren plätzen nicht so gut
geht deswegen schnappt ihr euch eure
köpfe und teil diesen ganzen ballen für
mindestens einmal in der hälfte und
damit kommt jeder einzelne von diesen
hälften in einen größeren topf so
ungefähr so was sollte der schon sein
wenn ihr die so ein fan ist dann habt
ihr so viel länger als von euren
pflanzen ich will jetzt einfach mal
[Applaus]
wir machen wenn es ein loch in der mitte
und setzen unsere basilikum pflänzchen
einfach so tief hinein wie sie auch in
der ursprünglichen töpfchen gesessen
haben ein bisschen andrücken rundherum
angießen nicht vergessen und wenn ihr
die dann auch noch richtig ernst sind
also immer die spitzen ab gehabt dann
habt ihr quasi unendlich lang was und
ein und demselben topf und mit nie
wieder den supermarkt rennen um euch da
die pflänzchen zu kaufen und wenn ihr
dann irgendwann so viel pesto erntet das
ist schon zu den ohren raus kommt dann
könnt ihr eure geernteten triebspitzen
auch in stecklinge verwandeln wenn ihr
lust habt dass ich euch mal zeigen wie
das funktioniert wie man aus einem
töpfchen basilikum quasi unendlich viele
neue basilikum pflanzen machen kann das
schreibt das gerne in die kommentare
ansonsten verlinkt ich euch da drüben
ein video das euch interessieren könnte
und dann geht raus macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner bord ganz weber sie
gekommen an und wir sehen uns nächste
woche samstag um zb ein neues video
vista